funny fact not yet though at this point
it's funny fat Saturn oh what is going
on you beautiful creature
now as you get older you start to
realize that a lot of people hold on to
they're used to bees
now we're not used to bees you asked
used to bees are everything that a
person mentions when you talk about [ __ ]
that they can't do now now I know you
know some of these dudes and they are
what you call annoying as [ __ ] now I'm
not talking about people who share fun
and personal stories about their past
because that's dope and that's how a lot
of people bond you know except for the
few times where you share a story that
only you can relate to don't you guys
love it when you [ __ ] that you study and
after I'd say that a before what are the
worst type of used to these are the guys
who constantly have to remind you about
their past fitness back in my bed I used
to bet light for the pounds back in my
bed sporting a [ __ ]
I know years ago hey nobody [ __ ]
cares probably ties to I tell you nobody
cares that you want to hear it in six
different languages I don't care I don't
give the [ __ ] I really don't care
nobody [ __ ] cares and [ __ ] it's funny
because it always pops up when you want
to share a story about yourself because
they ask and you want to tell them about
how you're progressing because you know
you feel good about yourself but these
[ __ ] always got to talk about
the past to tell you that you ain't [ __ ]
but let me ask you something can't you
do it now
but back in the day yeah no can you do
it now how about this put up or shut up
I don't want to see a video ho I don't
want to see pictures I don't want to see
you old crusty ass tears that you used
to be able to slip yourself right into
you can go ahead and talk about oh you
used to B's to go ahead and make
yourself feel better but the point is
just can't do it
now now I know a lot of you out there
are afraid to go to the gym because you
compare yourself to who you were before
because as long as you are out of shape
you can constantly tell people that you
can get that [ __ ] back whatever you want
stop bringing up your past and you're
used to these two other people who are
trying to get their fitness game up
because it doesn't help them because as
much as you try to tell other people
that you're sharing those stories to
make them feel better about themselves
your [ __ ] line you're doing it
because you want to feel better about
where you're at right now when I see
somebody who has out of shape and
overweight just like me huffing and
puffing and sweating in the gym that is
what that shit's about because despite
how difficult it is for them and for me
we're still trying because it is hard
enough to try to get motivated and make
a personal change that we don't need to
hear negative [ __ ] from people who are
fat just like us you know what that is
that's back on fat crime cuz that's not
laughing at somebody because they read a
book slow when you can't even [ __ ]
read you need to quit making excuses and
get your [ __ ] life together because
the past is in the past and presently
yet that is [ __ ] child triple fm you
already know that life is always what
you make it but it's up to you to take
what you deserve let's go for broke Oh
what is going on YouTube thank you thank
you for turning into triple F cuz you
already know we getting our fitness game
oh and yes after this video I'm about to
get out there in the gym or maybe not
even in gym because it's hot as [ __ ]
today and I'm gonna use that to sweat
this [ __ ] off but yes coming up this
Friday we will be dropping a couple of
new designs on go for broke and yes we
are gonna be putting that [ __ ] on sale
for you once again and I'm super excited
about one of the designs because it lets
freshers [ __ ] so remember I have my
Sunday upload as usual and once again
next weather you will get another triple
F video so keep it up and I've got to
cut this [ __ ] hair eventually because
look at this [ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
gotta do it so I gotta lose another like
I don't know I think that's about like
15 pounds now so I can cut my hair
get into my fitness game and keep it up
and do this for you guys just as much as
I am doing it for myself yes I will see
you all next time peace out
barbell breguet all day yes I work out
at that gym in Monterey Park check it
out you might see me do a little lift
like this with this every time they ask
you about your fitness and how you're
progressing and I just don't know these
are bad man everything that you used to
do to make yourself it make yourself
beer better hmm
you need a quick you need a quick you'll
need the link part enough to make a
check what the [ __ ]
much fun I say what am I trying to say
hmm tell me like what am I say